what's up peeps
welcome back to the quartering i mean uh
geeks and gamers
no popcorn planet sorry i'm trying to
just
real rejects welcome back to the channel
did it okay we have
a we have a headline here the batman
robert pattinson ready to quit because
of matt
reeves i'm gonna tell you guys
i believe this already it's already a
hundred percent true
undoubtedly sources said it these are my
favorite types of videos to do
because come on i
love them they're so fun one day i'll
take the drama seriously
one day we'll get up in arms and worried
about these let's
let's go through let's let's go through
this i i skimmed it
very skim i'm like perfect exactly my
medicine my juices i watch videos about
this kind of stuff all the time but we
rarely
uh obviously before this channel we
rarely do videos about this kind of
stuff so it's not
only when it's gonna be fun the only
ones to know author's one that's like
yeah that sounds fun
all right so this comes from the most
reliable uk
newspaper in the world the sun
the sun the most reputable yeah yes if
you guys don't know the sun
they're like the tmz of the brits so
here's
according to the sun oh i didn't even
read this part yet oh good
robert pattinson has been pushed to his
breaking point by matt reeves who is
said to be
a control freak on set
as reeves is requiring pattinson to do
upwards of 50 takes
inside the bulky batman suit leaving him
and the crew exhausted look man we're
just tired from watching that
we're exhausted through association of
watching robert pattinson
this is a secret method of getting him
to work out because he's in this bulky
batman suit so doing all that repetition
is probably building his muscles oh my
oh man i'm tired of the crew's all
exhausted you know he's probably the
tiredest is the boom guy
hey man that takes a lot of upper arm
straight he has to factor in the fact
that he has pointy ears
okay so the source for the site claims
um filming has been a grueling process
especially for robert as matt is such a
perfectionist
yeah you know he's just batman he's
freaking just doing it never
dies one get clint who cares
wonder clint gosh just call it a day
people are gonna watch it anyway i don't
need to be all perfectionist about this
what we've learned from our most recent
films is that you can put
any or no effort at all and people still
show us freaking matt reeves getting all
inspired by
damn david fincher and stanley kubrick
oh we saw that that batman trailer was
very much inspired by seven which is a
fincher film and fincher and jake
gyllenhaal had a similar debuggle
yep because he was asked to do upwards
of 50 it's always 50 takes it's always
50. it's
always 50 takes why is 35 not a little
unreasonable too
people always say that 50 takes
who's counting was it really 50 takes or
just a lot of takes
he'll insist on doing some scenes over
and over again
and get bogged down in the tiny detail
again it's batman and of course he sure
did did you not see what happened with
the last one
huge budget move and now they have a
[ __ ] of the situation
sometimes it's like he doesn't know when
to stop i can't
stop can't stop booming adjusting i
can't stop making this better
cinematography
run our brothers can't afford for the
fan base to be disappointed and have
thrown 90 million at the film
well yeah yeah duh yeah
why they hired a caliber filmmaker of
this degree was going to pour over these
if they have the time to make it better
make it better no one is denying that it
is a high stakes production and that
matt is feeling
the pressure to get it right good
robert has had a tough time on these
franchise movies before
he hated twilight by the time it wrapped
and the last thing
anyone wants for him is to become
[Music]
you know they always did like 100 takes
of all those scenes on twilight he
should be used to it this is my favorite
part this is the part i read which i
thought was so hilarious
oh this is true
matt reeves should not be making any
movies
for like the next two years it's
so ridiculous the site also
says that following robert pattinson
testing positive
for you know that thing that we can't
say as well as members of the crew that
matt reeves is
paranoid about catching it oh
oh really what are you doing what are
ridiculous they have all these safety
protocols
in store these preventative measures
they test all the time he's been filming
for a while
everyone on that set is likely to catch
it it's not just it's like no
it's just a pattern i'm worried about
man keep that guy away from you
all you guys are saying no one in video
of that
one guy right there video village in a
bubble i wanted to spend it in the
bubble above the set
this is so funny it's got to the point
now where he's been directing scenes
while
zipped up inside a puffer coat with ski
goggles on
as a secure outfit it's questionable but
if it makes them feel more at ease
everyone's going with it damn you matt
reeves
i i bet i bet someone caught a photo of
him
dressed like this it could be which i've
gone to like the supermarket i've seen
people wearing like sunglasses inside to
prevent them and getting in their
eyes and they're really covered up like
it's the dust bowl so people
really go all out you know and if you're
going to be on a set and you want to
make sure you don't get shut down
i bet i bet someone caught a glimpse of
that and was like oh we got a story to
tell
well and i'm also sitting here going
well what kind of day was it maybe it's
cold aren't they shooting in the uk it
gets cold yeah all the time it rains all
the time yes they're probably gonna add
more rain than the actual rain they have
available to them
all the time so part of me is going well
he could you know be all conspiracy
theoried out or maybe it was just a
reasonable day to be bundled up yeah
and the other hand is like i've heard
this about matt reeves before with the
perfectionism and i'm like okay i know
that
sometimes with these directors that can
get a little excessive
but at the same time i think you have an
absolute point it's like
we gotta get this batman movie right and
clearly we're trying to make
more of a film film than just a
blockbuster out of it
so like are we surprised and it's robert
pattinson too
yeah i think he'd be down for multiple
takes
i think he's the nitty gritty yeah he's
a he's an actor who likes to explore
so you know this is silly
it's funny it's funny it's true don't
buy it it's absolutely the fact
don't buy it this is the real thing i'm
telling you guys source said this though
all right guys well do you believe it
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
happy new year to you all i also want to
shout all the guys who are pledged to a
special tier on our rewards section on
patreon
and they get a patron of the name you
know what i'm trying to say
roll that do it josh barnes
sean mcplay
oscar zach
wright the jedi bro lauren american
horse cj thomas peter pacheco
russell beatty giant panda king joanna
meet me in st
louis matthew menzing
stephen mendoza sandrine little angel
body rot
rogue cree sam castle sj94
andrew baba runar k
martin kayla huatas teddy waters
rosie bubba baby darth yoda order 66
ruby tnt i'm dynamite
calgarian c pinnacuz philip j smith jr
jen smith brianna davidson
melanie matt leblanc brittany barely
natalie doran irwin reggie
marcus wurtzman
[Music]
smat beer loopy
gaming thank you all so much for being a
part of our patreon page hope you've
been enjoying the content over there
your support means so much
you've helped make 2020 surprisingly
a really all things considered a much
better year
at all so thank you guys so much for all
your help and all your support
looking forward to seeing y'all in 2021
thank you again much love